for some travellers the jubilee was no
cause for celebration as cancellations
and delays at airports turned the
holiday into a weekend to forget
heathrow avoided the half-term chaos and
they're confident they'll do so again
this summer when numbers peak for the
school holidays though the boss admits
it will take time for the whole industry
to recover from covid
well i think it'll take 12 to 18 months
for the whole industry to get all of its
capacity back to where it was before the
pandemic and that's not just
across the uk it has to be across europe
as well because we are affected by
staffing issues at other airports around
the world
and so this isn't quick
very skilled jobs have been lost and now
we're having to as an industry recruit
people back train them up again to be
able to serve passengers and that just
takes time
it's very easy to slam the brakes on the
industry lead to enormous job losses but
it's much harder to scale it up again
when you suddenly open the doors again
the airline industry was perhaps the
most ravaged by kovid 19 ending
international travel at a stroke wiping
out billions of pounds in revenue and
the return to normal has not been easy
the real test of how they're coping will
come in a couple of short weeks once the
school holidays and the summer travel
season begins in earnest
at bristol airport passengers queued
into the car park last month
to avoid a repeat they're on a
recruitment drive to fill more than 100
roles including security where training
remains a challenge
it can take up to 12 weeks to go through
security and training but we are able to
do some training ahead of the actual
start
and the issue of the past so we're
working around it as best we can the
real test of the industry's confidence
and passenger patience is about to come
paul kelso sky news at heathrow